what was that gnarly injury like I
didn't get that far in I had a few
um there was there's one that really
kind of shook me my family and
um the community that we lived in was I
crashed with Bob burn Quest and that was
really bad that was no I I was 11 years
old as an MTV Sports and music festival
were you there I don't know okay this is
way back I think Jamie Foxx was hosting
he showed up with an afro and these huge
socks and was like skateboarding like a
little dart board like a banana board
around the vert ramp chasing me there's
like some funny footage that we found
digging through the archive but I was
doing a doubles routine with Bob and we
collided mid session and and I was a lot
it was a one-sided fist fight I mean he
clobbered me and so I broke my hand I
broke my foot and I fractured my skull
and then I you know I get home and I
cruise into school and teacher just
looks at me starts crying everybody's
like you know it was a really it was a
really heavy thing that happened and
what was crazy about it was the reaction
of the community we lived in because
they're like oh
you guys got what you deserved you were
doing these sports that we don't
understand and look what happened to
your son like this was a matter of time
before this happened not like because we
knew we don't normally do doubles you
don't normally do these things it's not
like I tried some big trick and took
this crash it was like an accident but
you know the school tightened up on me
like leaving to go on you know trips for
competition everything kind of got weird
and then you know as a family like what
do you do when your your mom and dad and
you're like God everybody's looking at
us like those terrible parents that now
being that young and taking a slam like
that yeah do your parents take a step
back and maybe reconsider
like letting you go forward into chasing
this dream of snowboarding yes okay so I
don't want to give away too much to the
dog but there's this beautiful interview
with my mom where she's she's talking
about he's like so what do we do now
what's next she's like well I just got
to get him back on the ramp and they're
like what that's awesome and and you go
you know okay if your kid was in a car
accident you're not like let's just get
him behind the wheel we gotta get him
back in there you know yeah yeah it's
Talladega night what are you talking
about you know so she really was there
to be like I know he loves it because I
did I would cry if I couldn't go to the
skate park after school's My Punishment
like if you don't do the dishes you
can't go skate tomorrow and I'm like
rubbing all the dishes you know so I
just truly loved it and and so she knew
that if I you know had this you got to
get back on the horse and if if this one
incident like you know kept me from a a
career and A Lifetime Love of this Sport
and friendships and this like everything
I was gonna get from it she didn't want
to prevent that so she actually like
helped guide me back into skateboarding
I remember the day I was I was at the
skate park and I because I after the
crash you know the cast finally came off
I was like I don't know I just didn't
want to skate anymore I was over it and
she finally convinced me to go to the
skate park and I skated up to the fence
and I was like I'm over it like I don't
ever I don't want to do this anymore I
want to quit she's like all right well
I paid five dollars for you to do this
session so you're gonna finish this
session I was like you know what I mean
like just such a mom comment you're like
well I paid five bucks so you're staying
I was like fine I remember running over
the vert ramp I was killing some time
and I bumped into Kevin's knob
um you know renowned skateboarder
legendary guy you can spot his hair from
a mile away
um and he taught me basically backside
errors that day I could only do front
side errors and I you know what I mean
that feeling of learning a new trick I
was just like I was hooked all over
again and so that's what got me back
into skating but um but yeah those
injuries are something that's like it's
a hard thing to bounce back from and a
hard thing to get not only your physical
but like your mental straight especially
a fresher skull yeah that was rough and
what happened was the
you know when when I fracture my skull
the blood had pulled on my forehead and
what's called the hematoma and like and
then all the blood settled in my eyes
and so I just had these crazy black eyes
oh yeah I look like I cast on my arm and
my leg I like hobbling into class and
they just looked at me like what
happened when Kevin Staub teaches you a
backside air is it like an early grab or
a leg grab situation
I think it was late grab because I could
already
um you know I I envied another kid that
skated at the park
um gosh what was his name I think Steve
something
um he was a bit older than me and he was
the sweetest guy ever super super nice
but he skated for birdhouse and I was
like I hate this guy look he's gotta go
you know what I mean I just created this
like you know I don't want to say enemy
but like someone to rival with because
he I wanted to be friends with Tony he
was already on birdhouse I was like but
I remember the way that he all he would
Ollie before he yeah got to the top of
it ramp but I hit the coping with my
wheels and so that's how I kind of
figured that I could maybe start going
higher than him because I'm already
starting at a at a at a you know a
different way I guess you could say but
yeah I I remember learning it that day
and just like that feeling and and then
it just opened up this whole new world
of tricks for me and and then it just
kind of like went from there yeah yeah
when did the airbags come in to the
snowboarding and was that all you I seem
to think it was all you pretty much most
of it was inspired see I was I was
learning new tricks just you could
basically show up all right today's the
day I'm gonna go for this thing I'm
gonna I'm gonna wing it
um and what happened was a lot of guys
in the back country started doing these
double flips and they're doing double
flips because in the backcountry it's
deep snow it's powder it's a natural
airbag they can just chuck whatever you
know make mistakes but then it's all
good and so there's no real way to
replicate that in the half pipe so I
started kind of thinking about it and I
had gone to one of those Woodward camps
um where they had the big foam pits for
the gymnastics and then I saw Pastrana
trying his double backflips into the a
foam pad why the technology exists why
don't we tap into this and I can learn
some tricks and and so I link together
with the sponsor and we created this
half pipe setup with the foam pit and it
was supposed to be this big secret and
then it just became this very well-known
secret that I was doing it and to my
competitors in in a rush to keep up with
me where like they called their sponsors
and they're like we can't I mean we
gotta buy foam and ship it out and build
a container for it and all these things
and they're like well why don't we do
this airbag thing and so that kind of
started the airbag Trend and I was a
little annoyed I was like why didn't I
think of the airplane it's like way
easier the blocks were all getting you
know snowed on and then freezing
overnight like it wasn't this wasn't uh
your competitors did the airbags yeah to
combat what I was doing and I was like
dang I didn't even think of the airbag
that's way easier you know and so but
that's how it all started you know and
when that was around 2006 for that
excuse me in 2010 for the Vancouver
Vancouver right okay that was uh
dude that's crazy man and that that
could make so much sense that the foam
is gonna freeze oh yeah it'd get wet it
would freeze you're losing your goggles
and then the worst part is is that you
know when you go into a foam pit it's
not a pleasant feeling and when you have
a board on your feet like you're stuck I
couldn't get to my feet so the first
jump I go in and that that awful feeling
of like you're suffocating like the
goggles are over my face and I'm just
claustrophobic in the bottom of the pit
like
and everybody's sitting there watching
for good 15 like oh he can't get out
so then at a certain point Adam my dad
was just like lifeguard he would just
like come unstrap me and pull me out but
I became more nervous of the airbag than
actually excuse me the foam pit of you
know how I was gonna end up in it but
it's not foolproof I ended up uh when I
was learning the double MC twist I
landed in the foam and the way the foam
works is it's it's like you know uh it
kicks back it's springy and so as I
landed in it I I compressed and then it
started to push back and I my momentum
still carrying me forward so I felt this
like in my ankle and so I chipped a
piece of bone
um Landing in the foam pit and that's
what ended that whole session I was like
oh I can't I can't ride anymore it ended
the session yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
and that's so Danny Way yes yeah
um yeah yeah like how many surgeries are
have you done like ACLS and all that
stuff man so I really kind of pride
myself that my career was really built
off me landing on my feet I've watched
some docs and talked to any of these
guys and like man I've had
like I had the bad accident when I was a
kid so it's a broken hand foot and then
the skull and that's not really a joint
yeah that's not like a thing and so I
think it wasn't until I was 16 I had a
small tear and the lateral side of my
meniscus which is the padding in between
um right in your knee that keeps you
kind of is that what happened to Isaac
meniscus uh I think so yeah out of all
the knee injuries that's the less that's
that's the one you want because it's
like they can come in they clean it up
and you're good to go where the other
ones you either have to reattach a
ligament or tendon or you have to get a
cadaver right you know I hope it takes
yeah Isaac got the cadaver it's an ACLS
yeah so that one luckily I didn't have
to deal with and then I I like I like
ripped a ligament my thumb uh a lot of
concussions unfortunately and then um
and then the big crash in New Zealand
where I kind of ripped my face open
which really sucked that one was brutal
but that was kind of it do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now yeah
dude